good morning John and welcome to the
project for awesome 2023 meme review
during the project for awesome people
make things and then they submit them to
the project for awesome art folder
including this music that you're hearing
right now from ickle there was a whole
album of techno vlogbrother stuff I'm
still pretty hyped for awesome and the
two cups of black tea that I just had
five count them five folders on my
desktop that I have filled with stuff
relying on the fact that I have two
years in a row gotten permission to make
extra long videos I'm gonna do that
starting of course since it's a meme
review with the folder labeled memes
just like the project for awesome there
is no Rhyme or Reason to this you just
start somewhere in the middle and you
put the peeps in the bean can and add
the Dr Pepper all these powerful white
men are are laughing at John Green
because they put the Dr Pepper on Peeps
and at that point you have to do it I
don't know if I've said this before but
I actually wrapped like gift wrapped the
peeps and it said project for awesome
day one open on day one and then my son
thought it was a present for him and he
opened it at John house and just started
eating them sound financial decisions
and me being held back by sending two
middle-aged guys to a restaurant it's
twenty dollars and we are gonna make it
worth it everywhere I go I see his face
look I'm not necessarily proud I did buy
way too many
oh geez I just spilled pickle juice on
myself it wasn't totally sealed well I
do still have my paper towels because
it's project for awesome and the most
important thing is paper look at how
many paper towels I used let's just all
take a moment to be grateful for
Catherine green anyway I bought too many
pickles as all I wanted to say just
putting beans in the bean home I've got
a bean shirt on and a banana Loca in one
hand and a corn dog in the other any
cylindrical food is on the table I did
buy hot dogs this year and I didn't end
up using them next year project for
awesome audience just watching me
slapping Dr Pepper baked beads on an
unsuspecting pickle Hank Green slurping
Dr Pepper beans from a banana Loca
doesn't exist and can't hurt you oh yeah
you think so and I had to get them out
somehow I don't know I feel like
everyone was having a good time and I
stand by the fact that a Twinkie filled
with Dr Pepper baked beans is better
than a Twinkie knot filled with Dr
Pepper baked beans this is in reference
to the auction that we had for Ryan
Reynolds Deadpool screen worn watch me
and Ray were in a tight battle and then
Ben came out of the last second Chow
this is great because it does look like
he's joking but he is not joking Dustin
was responsible for the largest single
hour of the project for awesome this
year support the project for Awesome by
watching the live stream by voting on
videos by donating by getting married
and moving to North Dakota that's a deep
cut but that was a fun part of the
stream guests are ready signal strong
donation steady made a donation to the
project already Hank's confetti if you
got the confetti perk I've ordered some
special stickers to close these up with
I'm just waiting on that and then
they'll go out to you me before crabilis
me after I get a premium subscription to
have a crab in my inbox every month I
love this because I know the screen cap
that this video is from because Oren and
I watch it together all the time and we
dance Captain Crunch Gotta Love any
amount of Darcy that gets into the memes
me and John on both crunched a lemon and
it was bad both times crunch uh looking
at Darcy crunching a carrot instead of
me crunching a lemon and look I don't
know I feel like I put more into that
than Darcy did you can't defeat me
humans I know but she can that's right
Darcy crunching carrots was responsible
for us breaking through the two million
dollar barrier this wasn't like the
first moments of the project for awesome
where I was like I guess it's begun I'm
gonna make a hole in the bottom of a
peep that's Dr Pepper flavor and filled
with beans we didn't have to hit a goal
to get there or anything I just couldn't
stop myself and I don't know that John
liked it for every ten thousand dollars
we will reward Darcy with carrots
Nerdfighters Max Max Max
so his spaceship is very good friendship
ended with beans now hummus is my best
friend we that was the first mention of
hummus of this whole meme review I don't
know if anybody was happy to see the
banana Loca come back weirdly I now have
two because I was gifted one by a friend
who didn't know I had one who knew that
I would want one so I'm like this in
real life I a little bit like the part
where you don't like it like you have to
know that right I tried to Crunch a
carrot as good as Darcy I don't actually
think I did I think I did a worse job so
the story behind the hummus is that it
turns out one of the stock notification
sounds in slack is just a woman saying a
hummus I changed it because people
donated for me to change it and I left
it that way for the entire project for
rasa but I did mute the more active
slack channels and before I did that
there was a lot of hummus happening it
was a little overwhelmed yeah like this
and like that and like that doing 20 on
something I need spending twenty dollars
so two guys can go to a racks I don't
know if you needed that but I think that
we all needed that
yeah they knew ultimately it is a little
hard for it not to be a problem tummy
time the project for awesome but we work
through it I'm gonna donate for a perk
that is so being filled you don't
actually get any Bean filled perks
that's not that's not available yet
maybe next year adding a citrus
crunching a almond I don't know if it
was supposed to be lemon but it says
Ramen and that's great never ask a woman
her age a man his salary Hank wear the
slip of paper from the balloon win I
never found it maybe it's like in one of
these cracks or it like flew into the
bookshelf somewhere I never found it
someday I will we had to vote on who the
mascot of the 2023 project for awesome
lesson T-Rex clobbered hummus Lemon Lips
man was the other option uh it wasn't
even close this is great because the
meme is referencing itself fantastic
work John cannot be quiet about
tuberculosis at the moment but God bless
him for it John I love you for who you
are oh yeah when I crunch the limb and
my lips swelled up and I looked like
this guy from Monsters Inc also last
year I had to pretend to be a crab this
year I had to pretend to be a cute
little housefly and both times it
definitely hurt my knees I did decide
that the phone a friend task was too
easy so I taped my phone to my phone
which also might be part of the reason
why my knee hurts this is part of the
story of this year's project for awesome
we decide like we had to commit the bit
we had to make it a priority it's been
too long we've talked about racks and
not been to a racks we're gonna go to
Rex which might be a problem for our
pants but we're gonna do it anyway are
we gonna talk about why Rax is bad for
your pants it's very deep it's too deep
it's time to go was I a good restaurant
no you ruined pants
I don't even really know where it came
from this is great because it's destined
on the moon and he's Mr T which is
tuberculosis racks T-Rex is as well
hello the moon you can eat here it's
everything it's got everything all at
once marked safe from beans on a peeps
you're not you're never safe the two
Vibes of the project for awesome are a
little bit contradictory but I think
they come together very well someone
accidentally bid 42 000 for the watch
and we had to roll it back but luckily
we were able to do that stay up to date
on your vaccinations the internet's
hottest club is the p4a live stream this
place has everything Bean filled pickles
the word hummus fast food restaurant
chain rack honestly that list could have
gone on way longer and not gotten any
less weird big Lemon Lips a Furby made
of beans and dinosaurs going to the Moon
if you don't know about Stefan this
doesn't make sense but that's okay who
would win famous science educator or a
puzzle of electric rap the puzzle of the
electric rat one I actually found the
piece that I couldn't find after the
stream ending you think you're gonna get
beans no you mostly get slack hummus and
beans though baked beans no lemons no
lemon baked beans I put a little bit of
lemon juice in the Dr Pepper baked beans
and it was way it was so good it was way
better it needed something to cut that
sugar is there a world where I could
give Paul Hollywood a pickle stuffed
with baked beans because I feel like
that would be an achievement Destin kept
saying tataria which I understand it
looks like tataria now that I'm looking
at it to ataria is how it's pronounced I
like that spaceship that's a nice
spaceship sorry you're memeing the
concept of hummus and it was a good
mascot maybe just not the best they are
both the p4re I cannot disagree Hey look
it's the part where I had my phone taped
to my foot
and I called my friend Joe just drowning
in hummus I couldn't make it out who
would win one Hank Green or one lemon
boy one lemon boy would win
oh no was I just whining about my knee
the whole time I'm sure I was and that's
the end that's the end of the memes
everybody time to move on to the next
folder none of them are going to be
anywhere as long as the memes but we do
have one folder that's just called
hummus this almost ended up in the art
folder because it's beautiful oh my God
it's hummus hummus Hank trying to raise
money for charity the trains coming by
it says Hamas listening for hummus by
Hank Green special 16th anniversary
edition number one inside joke for
nerdfighteria of project for awesome
2023 evocative hummus meme Iraq's being
dipped into hummus this person knitted a
hummus thing hummus we're hummus because
we're hummus and finally a hummus Furby
and not the last one you'll see today
what's our next folder called you ask
it's called T-Rex and it's just rack
stuff this is a baby picture of me
taking the place of another child who
was in a racks commercial deep cut well
done Mr delicious as a T-Rex on the
earth so big he's going to space he's
almost at the Moon little T-Rex saying
hummus it was well established that
T-Rex only eats hummus and is a
vegetarian Hank and John's rack silent
Adventure ruin your pants be excellent
to each other that is absolutely what I
would look like in a crop top endless
salad bar and hummus an absolutely
wrextravagant trip with Hank and John
the boys are going to rack's number one
awesome project for awesome perk it was
the number two project for awesome perk
so pretty amazing T-Rex Mr P foreign I
will wreck your pants this guy's on a
skateboard because it's time to make
racks a priority we are rebranding racks
from the bottom up and it's gonna be
amazing here I am with a lemon in my
mouth riding on Mr D as a T-Rex I don't
know why I have so many tattoos racks
you can eat here endless hummus bar this
folder is just lemon stuff but there's
only four things in it I think I got
confused halfway through but here it is
this is a lemon crab saying hummus and I
think it's crank green so it's also me
if only it we're also a dinosaur I
didn't feel bad for the lemon before but
I do a little bit now you don't have to
understand that joke but there it is and
finally this it's a crab with lemon lips
and my glasses and it's got my press on
nails turns out impossible to play
guitar with the press on nails on your
string fingers and we cap it all off
with the last folder on my desktop this
one is just labeled art it's just art
it's things that were too beautiful for
me to It's called The memes including me
as a house fly that's a little bit too
well done it's kind of freaking me out
I'm giant I'm not a cute little fly I'm
a big scary fly I'm a big scary flying
man I have a lot of little hairs I would
love to get into carrot business just so
we can make organic Darcy crunch carrots
um good be weird do good if that's not
the project for awesome I don't know
what is for at some point I pretended to
be a crab while doing Shakespeare I
forgot about that until this moment this
is just my very large face with the word
beans superimposed over it because this
is becoming my brand
Eternal salad bar what a beautiful but
creepy racks very Twin Peaks Justin
going to the Moon in his spaceship car
five foot nine brown eyes and a sundress
which is just a Deering and John joke
it's this that's nothing to do with the
project for us I don't know if many
people would buy hummus if this was The
Branding but I know that I would we have
to stop saying now we're cooking with
gas we need to stop cooking with gas and
it's not even as good as solar powered
induction I could definitely see this on
a t-shirt but then you'd have to explain
it to people hummus somebody made a
winter project for awesome cookies
there's T-Rex there's crunching there's
a bean pickle there's crank green look
delicious really lovely we're here
because we are here spiral I don't know
how you do that that well little
darsiered watercolor a little crabulous
2.0 no watercolor a little Lemon Lips
watercolor tuberculosis focused Endeavor
project for awesome staple with lemon
crunch panic attack John Green a rabbit
hole crunch
it's beautiful we're hummus because
we're hummus also a thing that happened
a crab with the longest eyelashes you've
ever seen and a feather boa and some big
old lips beautiful project for awesome
mandala again another quite creepy Rex
image it's starting to feel kind of
threatening with the Eternal salad bar
this color pencil T-Rex is so huge he's
got a head of hair which you just don't
see on dinosaurs very often many of
these things seem like they would have
taken more than two days to do but I
don't know I don't like I don't know how
I've never made anything like this I
have no idea how hard it is to make but
it seems very difficult Lemon Lips no
hips that's me Hank Green a bean peep
a bunch of dogs pee for a you can cry
here it's in the founding documents it's
not required but it is encouraged I mean
we did the coffee club we did the sock
Club what's next this is gorgeous and
must have taken a very long time had to
be more than just a project for us a
project for awesome vision board you
just keep cramming stuff in because more
weird things are gonna happen this is so
cute he's wonderful
that's art right I don't like what am I
supposed to say T-Rex eating hummus and
destroying pants will Darcy carrot very
cute Tony orange I couldn't remember Ted
lasso's name and I knew that his last
name was a noun that's what my brain was
telling me okay if you look very closely
Mr delicious is inside of this T-Rex
he's swearing
the nerdfighteria turned 16 this year so
it's got a driver's license of course
and just so you know it is an organ
donor be gay moved to North Dakota
self-care is punk rock crunch two
million Kevin R.I.P Kevin's camera butt
city east and west so much is happening
that's Thomas just going around
everything oh that's beautiful Tony
orange believe me and John Pizza Man and
I guess
Bean boy I don't know what else to oh no
don't forget I said it Dustin's given a
press conference two just to notice a
bunch of dinosaurs I did break an egg
over my head I did immediately regret it
maybe they were trying to predict that I
would write butts on my head but I
didn't Sharpie face at all this yes it's
a beautiful self-care bunny well I love
you card and there's a crank green
inside of it down in the bottom of the
heart
so cute another doodle Board of things
going on you are on earth and no one can
take that away from you Hank Green's
hunky chasa 100 a profit to charity
we're queer because we're queer very
nice t-shirt design that's lemon it's
not having a good time I wasn't having a
good time nobody came out of this
interaction happy another collage
because we're here
p4a2023 dftba crunch I love this
triangle in the middle of the rainbow
it's really pretty
I don't know what to say about this
what's up with the giant space dinosaur
I don't know it's going to the Moon
obviously this is so great I love this
it's so adorable
dinosaurs in space Gumball Mike of
course John Green getting Sharpie faced
into from like a sort of Sigmund Freud
character here all the way to a very
punk rock figure and then there's Hank
Green Lemon Lips no hips again this is
very good but literally no hips in this
situation and I love that p4a logo you
made you are a Dino on the moon and no
one can take that away from you and
green in my new book The anthropubine
refilled
build can Edition my goodness and then
the beans in my pickle by crank Green Oh
I think all these were done by the same
person so I don't know who it was but
thank you it was genius crotch Tony
orange again P for a plus I think that's
basically the uh the digital download
bundle AS p4a Plus and then of course
there's this hanger fish crunching a
lemon he's lovely and he's made a
mistake certainly one of the greatest
pieces of project for awesome art this
year was these two long Furbies one is a
lemon hummus long Furby and the other is
a bean pickle long Furby with the crack
in it that the beans are coming out of
which did happen to my pickle it's not
really anything more perfect than that I
bought this as a sticker and I'm gonna
put it on my laptop because I love my
life we're hummus because we're a lemon
crab with gigantic lips a lot of people
make little compilation images of their
whole weekend I love them this was a
nice one a nice little Lemon Lips logo I
had the Lemon Lips John Green watercolor
sketch this little baby meeting it's
Mommy strong sad with a crab playing
with them you can't explain
but it was a nice moment I really feel
like it was the road to racks like it's
a video game level one we have to fight
that giant Dr Pepper peep then we gotta
fight the bean pickle then we gotta
fight the Lemon Lips and then we gotta
fight just a bunch of coffee beans
because at one point I did just eat raw
coffee beans and then last you gotta
fight Tyrannosaurus Rex cause it turns
out maybe a lot of the beauty Aesthetics
of that time came from thinking that
people with consumption were extra hot
it froze on John's face when he was
making that frowny face he was it was
like that for like a full 30 seconds and
it was such a perfect meme face it's
absolutely beautiful so you could just
drink cap that for any any use that you
want we're here because we're here but
it spells out hummus raising nerdy to
the power of awesome be weird do good
and it's a T-Rex at the Rex new item
Lemon Lips and it's just roaring out
hummus and finally the first piece of
art I saw and the last one I will show
you today is this 3D art of beans
stuffed inside of a Dr Pepper pea it was
a truly magical project for awesome
there were so many ridiculous beautiful
memorable moments there was this I'll
never forget that it was like I did a
magic trick but I none of it was on
purpose not even the confetti stuck to
the balloon there are a lot of ways to
find meaning and purpose in this world
but the project for awesome is one that
we kind of made up from scratch and it
is just ever so good I'm so grateful to
all of you who were a part of it in
whatever way you were and of course I'm
also very grateful to you John we had a
really good time it was a good old time
and now now I have to figure out how to
take all my lights down without getting
them all tangled and John I will see you
on Tuesday